[Music]
what's up guys and maybe showing you a
money making guide that has very low
requirements you just need 10
construction to move your house to tab
early and a cache stuck so what we're
going to be doing we're going to be
opening chests so first thing you want
to do you want to look at the
Dragonstone so it's at 22,000 so and
then we're going to be making crystal
keys and we want the crystal keys to be
at least 7 k less than are more than
this and if it's less than that then
you'll make you more profit so buy one
for mex price will buy a tooth half for
max price I can get the margins and then
by a crystal key just sometimes it's
cheaper normally it's not but we'll try
it ok so then sell everything back for
low and then let's see what the margins
are ok go to our history ok so if you
put them together it's about just over
28 k so buying the tooth teeth half and
the loop half key is slightly cheaper so
we can go ahead and do that want to buy
about 30 of them and by the other ones
and see the roadie buying so we'll let
that sit we'll come back when it's done
alright we're back so it took about five
minutes just want to go ahead and
collect those put it in our bank I
forgot to mention that to buy teleport
house tabs and rings of dual aimed to
make this quicker ok so take out when
you're doing take out six of each and
your house tab will go make sure your
house isn't Everly
toko their exit and so as you're running
down here start putting them together so
put them together as you write down
there I think this guys doing the same
thing and just use the key on the chest
over and over good items okay so we'll
pick those back up when we get back so
continue doing this club erecting
console wars continue doing this and
I'll tell you how long it takes and I'll
be back alright so I'm back so this is
where I've got and it took about six
minutes so i started with 1.5 mil and i
ended with about 100 1 mil 570 k so
about 70k in six minutes so if that's
right that should be about 700 k in an
hour so let's sell it and see what we
get
alright so I'm made about made about 60k
in six minutes so six to eight minutes /
6 Matt times the 60 so that's about 600
k in an hour so and if you get room
platelegs or more Runet bars or any of
that you can make upwards of two 900k
tower I've made almost a mill and now
we're doing this method alright so
thanks guys for watching stay tuned for
the next video